you might have heard of valheim the
recently released viking inspired
survival game where your goal is to
conquer the land and hunt down mythical
creatures
so you may ascend to valhalla like in
any good survival game the world of
valheim is full of danger and the game
expects you to figure things out for
yourself
but if you find yourself a little
overwhelmed after dropping off the
viking battle bus
don't worry we've got some beginner tips
to help you get started
and if you find these tips useful go
ahead and give us a like and sub
because that tells us that you guys
enjoyed this video
and we get to make more velheim tips
your first goal is going to be building
up a base camp
you'll need a fire to keep warm once
night kicks in a bed next to that fire
so you can sleep through the night and
have a respawn point
and a workbench so you can start
creating more advanced tools and
building structures
the trick is in order for the bed to
work it will need to be covered with a
shelter
you can place down a workbench and start
building your house right away
or even create the most bare bone
requirements for a shelter
but the best course of action would be
to take advantage of the many abandoned
houses lying around
they typically have just enough room to
fit a bed
chest and maybe even a workbench if you
tetris hard enough
and it will be the perfect temporary
accommodation for you while you build
your dream house
just make sure there isn't a beehive
already set up shop
[Music]
however abandoned houses aren't just
good for early game housing or the
occasional chest
fun fact they are made out of wood and
an excellent way to gather the resource
quickly don't waste time with your axe
though that is simply
too slow instead place a workbench next
to the structure
work benches allow you to build
structures within a certain range of
them
you can also dismantle any structure in
that range see where i'm going with this
using this method you can dismantle
abandoned homes in
seconds collecting the wood in the
process
just keep in mind that this will whittle
down the durability of your hammer
quite quickly now comes the time to
build your first home and we have a few
tips to make it easier for you
the terrain in bellahime is rarely flat
and smooth which
might be a source of frustration for
first-time builders
which is why the first thing you should
do is flatten the ground you're going to
build on using the hoe
you can craft one at a workbench that's
covered by a shelter
keep in mind that this isn't minecraft
and you can't completely transform the
landscape
the hoe is good for basic flattening and
raising up the ground in order to get it
smooth enough for a foundation for your
home
but what's the best way to actually
build a home
well these abandoned homes lying around
are actually built using these same
pieces you can create
which means you can simply copy or use
them as inspiration when building your
first structure
i would recommend making yours larger
though so you have plenty of space to
move around
and fill it with stuff final bit of
advice if you're struggling with getting
building pieces to connect to each other
instead of trying to place it where you
want it to be aim your reticle at the
side of the piece you want to connect it
to that was something that was tripping
me up at first
you'll likely go through a few axes and
hammers while gathering the necessary
materials for your home
however the item doesn't break once
you've exhausted it
so how do you repair them well turns out
it's quite easy
once you have your workbench under a
shelter you can craft and upgrade items
and tools
on the left of the menu is this little
square icon
tap that to repair one of your tools and
that's
it no cost or materials necessary as
long as you have access to the workbench
you can repair all your tools and gear
to your heart's content
by the way if you're like me and created
a few extra axes before you had
access to repair go ahead and throw
those in a chest
it's always good to have backups on hand
in case you meet your demise
once your basic needs are out of the way
you'll want to start focusing on
boosting your character's ever-growing
list of skills
how simply by performing that action
chopping trees levels up your axe
cutting
shooting arrows increases your archery
and so on these skills are
invaluable as they will actually carry
over if you bring your character to a
different
server saving you the hassle of
completely starting from scratch
be warned though a penalty for dying is
losing skill levels
so make sure not to be too risky you'll
naturally level these skills up by
playing the game but if you're looking
to improve a certain skill you can spend
the time
in a rigorous training montage find a
low level enemy and block them with your
shield
over and over or punch tree stump to
improve that hand to hand
[Music]
if you really want to get cheesy with it
though have a friend join your server
turn off pvp damage and then just swing
away
yeah it does feel pretty broken so don't
be too surprised if it's patched out in
a later update
boards are easy enough to find and kill
but it's always nice to have your own
personal hogs to
love and care for and slaughter for
resources
you might have seen a stone message that
implies it's possible to tame the
creatures
first thing you'll want to do is build a
basic pen make sure it's large enough to
hold several hogs
build a gate or leave an opening and
then go and find two hogs and aggro them
once they are nice and upset lead them
back to your pen and trap them
[Music]
and the hard part is done now you just
need to simply tame them
drop food like berries or mushrooms into
the pen and slowly over the next few
days
their tameness percentage will rise
until they love you
soon your pen will be filled with little
piggies who will eventually grow
into regular hogs giving you a nice
supply of meat
and leather scraps just remember to keep
throwing food into the pen for them
we hope these beginner tips will help
you get started on your viking journey
if you have any good advice for those
starting out that we missed post them in
the comments below to help your fellow
players out
thanks for watching and good luck
becoming a viking warrior
[Music]
you